- [Instructor] We're
now going to talk about
the beginnings of one
of the most important
religions in human history.
And, even today, the
largest religion on Earth.
And that, of course, is Christianity.
And the central figure in
Christianity is Jesus Christ.
And the term Christ is given to him.
It is Greek for savior, for messiah.
Because his early followers view him as
the prophesized messiah,
savior, for the Jewish people.
And his followers today view him as
the savior, the messiah,
for all humankind.
So, you have over two billion Christians
who view him central to their faith.
Who view him as their god.
But, above and beyond that, you also have
over a billion Muslims who view him
as a significant prophet.
Now, just to get some context
on the life and times of Jesus,
most of the accounts we have of him
come from the first four books
of the New Testament of the Bible
called the Gospel of
Matthew, Gospel of Mark,
Gospel of Luke, Gospel of John.
Sometimes it's the Gospel According to
Matthew, Mark, Luke, or John.
And the term gospel today often
refers to the idea of the life
and teaching of Jesus Christ.
So, you could view it
as the life and teaching
of Jesus Christ according to Matthew,
according to Mark, according
to Luke, according to John.
But it really comes from
old English for good news.
And there is a related term, evangel.
You might have heard of
evangelical or evangelize.
Also referring to good news.
Now, the reason why it
was considered good news
is his message....
We're gonna have some examples
of it in a few minutes.
Really talks about this idea that
the poor have the kingdom
of heaven waiting for them.
That there's this forgiving God
that you can have a close connection with.
And for a lot of people...
Remember, this was in the
time of the Roman Empire.
Most people were downtrodden.
There was slavery.
People who were poor.
And this idea that even the poor
could go to the kingdom of heaven
and, in some ways, have
better access to it
than the rich and the powerful
was good news to a lot of people.
Now, it's worth noting that these gospels
were written several decades after,
depending on what you view,
the death and/or ascension of Jesus Christ
according to Christian belief.
As you can see, Jesus was born
slightly before the year one.
Most historians put his birth at around
four to six BCE, Before the Common Era.
And they put his death around
30 to 33 CE, in the Common Era.
You could also use the original terms,
Before Christ and Anno Dominei,
In the Year of Our Lord.
Our modern calendar system really uses
the original view of the birth of Jesus
as where we start Anno
Dominei versus Before Christ
or the Common Era versus
Before the Common Era.
Now, it's interesting
that it turns out that
Jesus was likely born slightly before.
Slightly before the original
view on the birth of Christ.
Now, his birth would have
been right around the time...
Or it would have been under
the reign of Emperor Augustus,
as we talk about in other videos.
And his death would have been
under the reign of Emperor Tiberius.
And these Gospels of Mark,
Matthew, Luke, and John.
These are written during really hard times
for the Jewish people and
for the early Christians.
You have the Jewish Rebellion
where the Second Temple
is destroyed by Rome.
You have the significant
Christian persecution,
especially by folks like Emperor Nero
where he blames the fire
in Rome on Christians
and he just, essentially,
just kills them for fun.
Really just to purge
them, to persecute them.
And, just to understand where
all of this takes place,
the life and times of Jesus takes place,
it is in the Roman Empire.
We're on the eastern edge of it
at the eastern Mediterranean
right over here.
This would be modern day Israel
and Palestine for the most part.
This is a zoomed in version.
And Jesus is born in Bethlehem.
And this is a scene.
I'm gonna show you a lot of paintings.
As you can imagine, he's a figure
that has inspired a lot of paintings.
This is a figure of the three magi
visiting and giving their
gifts to the infant Jesus.
Magi, famously the Zoroastrian priests,
coming from Persia to visit Jesus,
according to biblical accounts.
And he is raised in Nazareth.
And that's why he's oftentimes
referred to as Jesus of Nazareth.
And the gospels don't talk
a lot about his early life.
They start to talk a lot about his life
once he hits his late 20's or early 30's.
And the first really significant account
after his famous birth to the virgin Mary.
His purported father,
Joseph, was Mary's husband,
but the Holy Ghost or God
was the actual father,
making this a virgin birth.
But, after that, the
first significant event
is really his baptism by John the Baptist.
John the Baptist was another preacher,
prophetic figure of that time.
A significant one.
He had a lot of followers.
And he as baptizing people
in the Jordan River,
right in that region.
This is the Jordan River right over here.
And this is a depiction of the
famous baptism of Jesus
by John the Baptist.
And, famously, John the Baptist said,
"No, you should be baptizing me."
But then after Jesus said,
"No, no, you baptize me."
And, after, Jesus was baptized.
Famously the sun shines on Jesus
and God speaks that "This is my son."
According to, once
again, biblical accounts.
And John the Baptist, shortly after that,
gets arrested by King Herod of Galilee.
Remember, Galilee is
the home region of Jesus
where he will eventually
do most of his preaching.
And, after that, Jesus starts to really
go full into effect in his ministry.
And, while he's doing that,
he's performing all of these miracles.
He's healing people,
turning water into wine,
walking on water, bringing
people back from the dead.
And this is, of course,
according to biblical accounts.
You can decide if you
believe these or not.
And he does most of that in Galilee.
And, eventually, he makes
his way down to Jerusalem
to meet his fate.
He tells, according to the Gospels,
his followers, his disciples....
And there's 12 in particular
that are called out,
but he has many, many more than that.
That "Look, I am going
to meet my fate there,
but I'm doing it willingly."
But, more than his
miracles, it's interesting
to look at some of what he preached.
And this might give you a
little bit of a sense why
many people would have
called this good news.
So, this is from the Gospel of Matthew
that I'm gonna quote right over here.
And this first part comes
from his Sermon of the Mount.
He goes to the top of a mountain
and he gives this sermon.
"Blessed are the poor in spirit:
for theirs is the kingdom of heaven."
"Blessed are the meek: for
they shall inherit the earth."
"Blessed are the merciful:
for they shall obtain mercy."
"Blessed are the pure in heart:
for they shall see God."
"Blessed are the peacemakers:
for they shall be called sons of God."
So, all of that, if you're a peasant,
if you're someone with not a lot,
you're downtrodden, hard life.
You're like, "Look, blessed
are the poor in spirit:
for theirs is the kingdom of heaven."
you could view this as good news.
"Ye have heard that it was said
an eye for an eye and a tooth for a tooth,
but I say unto you, resist
not him that is evil.
But whosoever smiteth
thee on thy right cheek,
turn to him the other also."
Even in modern times,
this is not an easy way...
This is not an easy way to live.
Someone who's doing something to you,
don't try to seek revenge.
And this is a very different tone
than a lot of what you might
get in the Old Testament.
"Ye have heard that it was said,
thou shalt love thy neighbor
and hate thine enemy,
but I say unto you love your enemies
and pray for them that persecute you."
Once again, not an easy thing to do.
Even in modern terms, you can view this as
a very forward, very advanced way
of thinking about the world.
He also, beyond this idea of
embracing even your enemies
and not seeking revenge and that the poor
have access to this kingdom of heaven,
he really also liked to
take it to the hypocrites,
especially those who viewed themselves
as the bearers of the religion.
In particular, he picks on the Pharisees,
which was a sect of Jews at the time
who viewed themselves very ritualistic.
Remember, Jesus, himself,
is a Jewish preacher.
He's a Jewish teacher.
He is viewed as a rabbi himself.
"And when ye pray, ye shall
not be as the hypocrites.
For they love to stand and pray
in the synagogues and in
the corners of the street
that they may be seen of men."
So, these hypocrites, they
pray just so other people
can see how religious they are.
"Verily, I say unto you, they
have received their reward."
They've already gotten the
credit from people for praying.
"But thou, when thou prayest,
enter into thine inner chamber
and, having shut thy
door, pray to thy Father
who is in secret, and thy
Father, who seeth in secret
shall recompense thee."
So, don't make a big
deal about your prayer.
Do it in private and then have this
personal connection with God.
Now, it's worth noting that,
even though he preached a lot
about the kingdom of heaven for the poor,
prayer is a private thing,
that you shouldn't try to seek revenge,
you should be very
conciliatory to your enemies,
he did take a strong stance
on what he was preaching.
He did say, "Look, you gotta be with me
if you want to enter into
this kingdom of heaven."
He took some strong stances.
This isn't gonna be an easy thing
and this is gonna cause a lot of tension.
This is one quote that
you could view that way.
Once again, from the Gospel of Matthew,
"Think not that I came
to send peace on earth.
I came not to send peace, but a sword.
For I came to set a man at
variance against his father
and the daughter against her mother."
I would interpret this as saying this is
gonna cause a lot of divisiveness.
"And the daughter-in-law
against her mother-in-law.
And a man's foes shall be
they of his own household.
He that loveth father
and mother more than me
is not worthy of me.
And he that loveth son
or daughter more than me
is not worthy of me.
And he that doth not take
his cross and follow after me
is not worthy of me.
He that findeth his life shall lose it
and he that loseth his life
for my sake shall find it."
So, he takes a pretty strong stance.
"Look, you really need to follow me.
But, if you follow me, there's some
very good things that
are waiting for you."
But, eventually, he does make his way...
He tells his...
There's other....
These miracles he's performing.
This is the famous
Transfiguration of Christ
where he makes it
apparent to his followers.
He kind of becomes luminescent
and he becomes apparent to
his followers, his disciples,
that he truly is the son of God.
And then, he makes his way...
This is the year, depending on whether
you think it's 30, 31, 32, 33 CE.
He makes his way to
Jerusalem to meet his fate.
He's already prophesized to his followers
that this is gonna be a tough fate.
That he's gonna die there.
And this is a very important
week in Christianity.
It's referred to as Passion Week.
And the term passion has
a different connotation.
It really means the suffering of Christ.
This is the week that he suffers.
This is the week that he gets crucified
and then resurrected.
So, he goes to Jerusalem on Sunday.
This is around the time of Passover.
Very important religious
period for the Jewish people.
And he comes to Jerusalem near Passover.
That Sunday that he comes is
now celebrated as Palm Sunday.
This is imagery of it where he's coming
and some people are
greeting him to Jerusalem
as kind of a king.
They're laying down these
palms before his path.
Then, this is the famous where he goes to
the main temple at Jerusalem
and he cleanses it of the moneychangers.
He's like, "Hey, by doing
these money transactions here,
you are defiling the temple."
Then, on Thursday of that week,
he has the famous Last Supper.
Some people believe this
is the Passover seder.
Most historians don't think it is.
But he's meeting with his 12 disciples.
And he's saying, "One of
you's going to betray me."
And it's Judas Iscariot who does.
And he goes to the religious court
and he says, "Hey, I have this guy
who you guys don't like."
Remember, this whole time that Jesus
is doing his ministry, he's sticking it...
In a lot of ways, he's
calling out these Pharisees
and these religious
officials as hypocrites.
He's getting all of these followers.
A lot of these traditionalists are saying,
"This guy's blaspheming.
He's saying he's the son of God.
He's saying all of these things.
He's doing these miracles on the Sabbath,
when you're not supposed
to be doing anything."
And so, Judas Iscariot
goes to the Sanhedrin
and says, "Hey, I have this guy.
Come and get him."
And they get Jesus and this is the famous
trial of Jesus by the Sanhedrin.
And they say, "Hey, you've
been saying all these things.
We think you're blaspheming."
And Jesus stays silent for the most part.
So, they deem him guilty
and they hand him over to
the Roman governor Pontius Pilate.
And they say, "Hey, look, this guy's
trying to create an
insurrection against Rome."
Which the Romans take very seriously.
And, in the Bible, they have him
seeming somewhat reluctantly saying,
"Oh, okay, do we really need to do this?"
But then he says, "Alright, if that's
the way you all want it."
And so, the Romans crucify Jesus.
And this is what is now
viewed as Good Friday,
The crucifixion of Jesus.
And then, on Sunday,
and this was predicted
by Jesus to his followers,
he is resurrected.
He leaves the tomb where he was.
And this is a very important week.
You have Palm Sunday.
You have Good Friday.
And then, you have the resurrection.
And then, another very, very
important event to Christians
is 40 days after the resurrection.
So, after 40 days...
Over that 40 days after the resurrection,
he's seen by his followers.
He's seen by many people.
He continues to preach.
And then, you have the ascension
where he goes to the kingdom of heaven.
Now, I'm gonna leave you with a quote
by a famous Christian historian.
And it's a fascinating one.
And it's very clear,
because we just talked
about the crucifixion
and you see a cross at every church.
"Christianity is the only major religion
to have as its central event
the humiliation of its God."
That's Doctor Bruce Shelley.
And whether you believe in Christianity
or you don't believe.
Whether you're an atheist.
Whether you believe in
the miracles or you don't.
It's worth pointing out that
Christianity has grown from this religion
that started around this
preacher in Galilee and Judea
and now has over two billion adherents.
And what was it about this religion
and its central event being
the humiliation of its God
that made it so appealing to many,
especially in that early Roman Empire,
both to Jews and to non-Jews, to Gentiles,
and has made it such a
significant religion?